so the question is do I have a god
complex which makes me wonder if this
lawyer has any idea to the kind of
grades it takes to be accepted to a top
medical school or if you have the
vaguest clue how talented somebody must
be in order to lead a surgical team I
have an MD from Harvard I am board
certified in cardiothoracic medicine and
trauma surgery and I have been awarded
citations from seven different medical
boards in New England and I am never
ever sick at sea so I ask you when
somebody comes in to that Chapel and
they fall down on to their knees and
they pray to God that their wife doesn't
miss Carey or that their daughter
doesn't bleed to death or that their
mother doesn't suffer acute neural
trauma from post-operative shock who do
you think they are praying to now you go
ahead and you read your Bible Dennis and
you go to your church and with any luck
you may actually win the annual raffle
but if you're looking for God he was an
operating room to on november
seventeenth and he does not like being
second-guessed you ask me if i have a
god complex let me tell you something i
am god